make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
you never close your eyes anymore when i
kiss
your lips hello everyone
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are getting an origin for ultraman right
the earth 3
superman it's about time only took dc
comics like 60 years to do it uh so this
is cool
right i'm really excited about this now
this comes off the tails it really is
it's kind of a backup feature for the
main crime syndicate mini series which
is really the first time
in in their history that dc comics is
actually developing any real measure of
explanation
to the crime syndicate which is which is
really really really really cool but
because it's a backup feature it's
basically like five pages long right so
it's not a super lengthy origin so just
something to bear in mind as we go
through this this will be relatively
short
but a lot of the stuff that we're kind
of given here is pretty identical to
the uh the superman mythos that we're
aware of right there was the doom planet
krypton that the the parents of superman
basically put him on a ship and then
sent him away
and he basically arrived on earth where
he was discovered by what were
effectively the kents right the big
difference here when it comes to earth 3
and i feel like this needs to be
explained as opposed to the main dc
universe
is that an earth 3 everything's kind of
different right it's it's
it's opposite but only with so many
limitations so the way the dc comics
originally did earth 3 and when i say
originally i mean back before
crisis on infinite earth is that the
main people on earth right the average
person you me
anybody else largely had like good moral
values we did good things right there
was
almost identical to the way that people
operated in the main dc universe the
difference is that the superheroes were
the ones who were twisted right so the
superheroes were the bad guys they
didn't really care about anything else
aside from consolidating power
making money that kind of a thing uh
eventually dc changed that so that earth
3 was a situation whereby
the people on on that earth were
basically bad people right that all
anybody cares about is just acquiring as
much wealth and power as possible there
were a few events or circumstances where
things were different were kind of
flipped on the opposite end but they
couldn't really get carried away with
that right you couldn't really have a
situation where like the british
won the revolutionary war because that's
not what happened here in the main dc
universe and so you're just doing the
opposite right you couldn't really do
opposites in that most extreme because
then it would start throwing in
continuity issues and so
a lot of what you saw with the earth 3
crime syndicate universe was really more
of an opposite of the main dc universe
insofar as like personality now some of
the roles are a little bit different and
we'll talk about some of the differences
in those roles when we talk about the
actual crime syndicate story right for
example like
jon stewart is an evil green lantern and
the guardians of the universe in the
earth 3 universe
are called the overlords of the universe
so we'll talk more about that as we kind
of get into that but again at the moment
we're focusing on the origin of ultraman
here and so what we end up kind of
finding out is of course its powers
manifested early on just like they did
with the main dc universe superman that
his parents basically found out about it
just like with the main dc
uh universe superman but what ended up
happening is that his powers he actually
started using his powers
publicly and that was something that you
never really saw with the
main dc universe superman that was the
significance of lana lang
lana lang was basically one of the
people that lived inside smallville
who was one of the only individuals out
there who was aware of the fact that
superman had powers and lana lang was
actually the person that helped him
learn how to use his powers right that's
the significance of her character in the
main dc universe comics
here there doesn't really seem to be
alana lang right there's nobody there to
kind of coach him and teach him and show
him that yeah you know you can't really
use your powers publicly or anything
like that
and so a lot of the taunts that he got
came from other kids who would refer to
him as like a freak or
space baby or bizarro or something like
that and it's one of these things where
his parents
always seem to kind of be there to
console him but started instilling in
him
ideas like obedience and that's the big
difference between like john and martha
kent or whichever version of the kent
you want to call them
in dc comics is that they taught clark
kent that with all this power that he
has
that he can't like rule over society he
cannot make people do things and yes
it'll be unfair
yes there are times when he feels like
he should step in but he can't
because the world has to make his own
way that he has to be a model he has to
be
something that's there that people can
strive towards but not something that he
basically drags people into a future
because they'll reject it right
the only way for true change to happen
among people is they have to be willing
to change on their own
and so in this universe here she talks
to them about things like obedient right
like you show them how to be obedient
you show them how to do what they're
told things along those lines because he
represents a higher level of power and
so again it's one of these things where
ultimately what ends up happening
is that his parents basically take him
of course to the barn as we usually you
know as we've seen so many times before
and present him with the fact that he
arrived on earth in a spaceship and
that's one of the things that they kind
of say here right you know like they
basically say things like we didn't want
anybody to know about you to know about
your powers to know that you were
special
we were trying to protect you we were
trying to you know keep you from being
taken away from us
because they would probably try to
enslave you or make you work for the
government or something along those
lines but a lot of the the
kind of parental reaction that you would
normally expect right like we were
trying to keep you
safe and so when it's revealed that he
arrived on earth in a spaceship and
comes from space he immediately freaks
out because that's when he starts to
realize all the kids were right when
they called him like a space baby and a
freak
not in so far that he is a space baby
and he is a freak that's not really the
case but in the sense that
they all knew he came from space and
that's one of the things that he kind of
picks up on with his parents is that
they lied to him right they lied to him
about the fact that no one out there is
supposed to know where he comes from
that no one out there is aware of the
fact that he arrived here on a spaceship
or anything along those lines all they
know is that he seemingly had some kind
of powers and all the teasing that he
got and being made fun of constantly
when he was being told like you're a
space baby you're a freak you're an
asteroid kid that he largely just kind
of attributed that to this this notion
that he had powers and they assumed that
like he must not be from here or he's
just some kind of a
alien or something along those lines but
just nonsensical terms that are used by
kids who just didn't really know what
they were talking about
the reality is they didn't know what
they were talking about more so than
that he starts to put two and two
together and comes to this realization
that the idea that his parents had of
keeping him protected from the world was
never really for his benefit it was
never really to to keep him safe to make
sure that like the world couldn't take
advantage of him it was to keep
themselves in this kind of position of
power
right that seemingly the reason why a
lot of the kids used to give them a hard
time but the parents of the kids would
never give them a hard time is because
it was always kind of this idea among
the kids that like if you bring
if you give us a hard time we'll kill
you right our child will destroy you
or something like that almost kind of
forcing this town to live in fear
and so because of that the kids didn't
really have that same kind of fearful
attitude that their parents did because
as we know
when you're a kid usually because you're
foolish you end up feeling fearless and
so because of that the kids didn't have
that same kind of issue right they would
make fun of him that kind of a thing and
there was no indication that he would
eradicate them right because even he
didn't fully understand
what was happening and where he was
coming from and that's when he realizes
like you didn't want me to go anywhere
he didn't want anybody to know about the
powers that i have
because you wanted to use me right you
wanted to use me to to keep this town in
control or whatever the case is and so
ultimately he ends up kind of lambasting
him right tearing him apart and just
saying like like i don't want to have
anything to do with you and ultimately
bailing out now something to understand
here
do not let this origin story lead you to
feel bad
for for earth 3 ultraman he's a dick
right like he's a terrible human being
like do not feel bad for this guy right
this is designed to kind of show you how
he got to that point but the truth is
that on this earth where you have the
his parents acting in this way everybody
acts in this way it's the way that it is
here on earth three
everybody only ever cares about their
own personal interests the interests the
values the feelings of other people
don't really matter it's just the
constant pursuit of power
and being willing to sacrifice whatever
you need to in order to get to that
point so
this is cool right i'm really really
digging this i'm hoping that we get some
more out of it
andy schmidt was the one who wrote this
and it's really really really really
good um i'm hoping that we kind of get
these little backup features for all the
other members of the crime syndicate but
if you've not read the crime syndicate
issue we can cover it if you guys want
me to we can cover if you guys are
interested in doing that i don't see any
reason not to
but it's really good in some ways it's
you know a little
you know and kind of a throwback to to
like you know it almost feels like 1990s
comics
especially with kiram account drawing it
uh it's not terrible no don't get me
wrong it's not bad it's just kind of it
almost feels like a comic you would have
seen in like
1999 from dc comics but uh but it's cool
right it's a cool story and i definitely
dig it let me know what you guys think
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you